car jouer bonjour merci d'être avec nous
olivier joueur a jugé hier je cite que
cette date du 11 mai est un objectif
très ambitieux le premier secrétaire de
votre parti le ps préférerait une date
glissante pourquoi mais parce que
aujourd'hui avons-nous les garanties
suffisantes et nécessaires pour imaginer
un p confinement des français en toute
sécurité
avons-nous toutes les garanties
permettant d'assurer demain ensemble des
tests sérologiques qui devront être
appliquées dans le pays pour éviter une
deuxième vague du virus à temps une
capacité d'annonce sur le nombre de
masques qui seront fournies aux français
dans les jours et les spectacles est en
l'occurrence pas encore donc nous
souhaitons maintenant qu'après sept
césar dont j'ai prise dans ma réplique
le gouvernement puis à signer les choses
affiner le calendrier et surtout rentrer
dans un certain nombre de précisions qui
nous paraissent importantes pouvoir et
ouvrir des écoles quand on les fait
restaurants fermés notamment partie des
questions qui nous interroge vous poser
beaucoup de questions
ce matin ça veut dire que vous n'avez
pas encore les réponses non on n'a pas
encore les réponses et puis vous savez
j'entendais natacha polony qui parlait à
l'instant sur notre antenne de nouveaux
convertis moi je n'attend pas d'un
président de la république de
gouvernance et simplement des beaux
parce que les boues ça fait bien
longtemps qu'il nous les donne moi ce
que j'entende désormais ce sont des
actes voyez vous on est rentré dans une
période où pendant cette crise nous a
d'abord dit que les masques ne servait à
rien vous avez me dit que ce ne serait
qu'une grosse grippe est aujourd'hui on
nous annonce que finalement ce serait
intéressant de pouvoir équiper la
population en basque b qu'on ne sait pas
encore quand on dort à des basques on
n'a pas de volonté sur des tests
sérologiques à grande échelle de la
population alors que je constate que nos
voisins européens sont en train de le
faire et c'est ce qui permettrait à
priori d'être une bonne réponse même
l'organisation mondiale de la santé le
préconise donc aujourd'hui on a besoin
de réponses plus claires moi je prends
acte clairement d'un certain nombre
d'avancées de la part du président de la
république hier soir mais on doit
rentrer dans les précisions
natacha polony natacha polony
1 notamment la responsabilité également
des gouvernements précédents notamment
françois hollande jean-marc ayrault le
ps est il responsable de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui de cette désorganisation
je ne sais pas en tout cas je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas les éléments pour le dire je
pense que ceux qui sont peut-être
responsable c'est ce qu'ils sont quand
ils sont arrivés au pouvoir avaient des
capacités d'action qu'ils n'ont pas
voulu mettre sur la table moi j'entends
ce que thil marisol touraine affaires
sociales et la santé notamment sur la
question des masques elle dit que quand
elle est partie il y avait un stock de
masques qui a été bien plus grand que
celui qui a été annoncé aux députés pris
le temps de la recherche de culpabilité
aura lieu une fois que la crise sera
terminée sera derrière nous et qu'on
devra repartir de l'avant pour
reconstruire notre pays je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le débat un débat il est
d'apporter des réponses des solutions
aux français des réponses aux français
qui s'interrogent et qui souffrent moi
je pense aux restaurateurs je pense aux
commerçants je pense aux petits
entrepreneurs dans les territoires
périurbains dans les territoires ruraux
qui aujourd'hui sont en grande
difficulté et à qui on a donné hier
trop peu de perspectives et je voudrais
pas que après cette crise sanitaire
on se retrouve sur un choc économique
qui soit d'une violence telle qu'on ne
soit pas en capacité de remonter la
pompe demande moi j'ai entendu un bain
d'huile bakr ont parlé d'adulation dette
mais je n'entends pas parler de la
négociation européenne qui est en train
de mener sur le financement notamment de
corona pont qui dansaient l'écho d'un
petit côté m donc tout ça reste à
éclaircir j'espère qu'il va leur arriver
et en tout cas nous le souhaitons
justement demain il ya un conseil des
ministres pour voir tout le côté
financier par rapport à cette crise
qu'est ce que vous attendez de ce
conseil des ministres de demain
mais il faut que ce conseil des
ministres demain soit extrêmement clair
extrêmement clair sur les plus fragiles
de notre pays
emmanuel macron l'a dit hier et moi
j'attends vraiment là-dessus qu'ils
soient à lons et je salue ce qu'il a
annoncé hier soir que ce soit sur les
travailleurs précaires que ce soit sur
les étudiants qui sont en difficulté
auront précarité que ce soit sur
les enfants qui aujourd'hui ne mangent
pas à leur faim dans notre pays ils font
lettre les moyens sur la table pour ne
pas créer des ruptures qui soit
irrémédiable dans notre pays moi
j'attends aussi par exemple que la
réforme de l'assurance chômage soit
annulé totalement parce que dans les
jours et semaines qui viennent ce sont
aussi des millions de femmes et d'hommes
qui vont se retrouver avec une indemnité
moindre que celle qu'il devrait pouvoir
avoir et ça va être une catastrophe
j'attends aussi qu'il y ait un grand
plan qui soit annoncée notamment pour
les commerçants pour les artisans et
pour les restaurateurs parce que leur
nom activités économiques me fait
craindre que ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
les les premiers à faire tourner cette
économie française depuis des années ne
soient en capacité de repartir parce
qu'on sait que c'est des entreprises qui
ont une petite trésorerie
on sait que c'est souvent des
entreprises familiales avec un voire
deux salariés et s'ils n'ont pas les
moyens de reprendre très vite leurs
activités après la crise économique
alors on va se retrouver dans une
situation où non seulement notre pays
sera affaiblie économiquement mais où en
plus de ça on va créer des ruptures
territoriale et géographiques qui seront
plus forte parce qu'on sait que c'est
dans les zones rurales ou dans les zones
périurbaines que ces petits commerces de
proximité ou susceptible d'entreprises
vont cesser leur activité donc on doit
changer de modèle on doit changer notre
manière de raisonner et aujourd'hui dans
cette crise on doit avancer main dans la
main on doit avancer soudée mais avec
des mesures concrètes et plus simplement
des baux justement parlez beaucoup de
social avant le discours des manuels
m'apprend hier soir le ps après a imposé
un état d'urgence sociale est ce que
vous avez obtenu les réponses que vous
espériez dans l'allocution du président
on est déjà en état d'urgence en état
d'urgence sociale ça veut dire quoi en
part qu' on en a obtenu certaines
garanties et certaines réponses dans
l'allocution de maintenir est est ce que
je lui disais la ligne en oeuvre sur les
travailleurs précaires sur les étudiants
sur les familles les familles nombreuses
etc
mais ce qui est le plus important
aujourd'hui va s'orienter notamment sur
la question de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage
la récente de l'assurance chômage que
nous avons combattu qui a été mise en
place dans ce pays
elle fait que l
supprime des droits à des femmes et des
hommes qui cotisent et qui se retrouve
aujourd'hui au chômage et qui vont avoir
une indemnisation moindre eh bien on
s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui on a des
millions de femmes et d'hommes qui sont
au chômage partiel
donc il faut remettre à plat totalement
ce qui avait été mis en place
il me fut gc demain comment garantir
notamment l'accès à leurs salaires pour
des millions de femmes et d'hommes qui
travaillent dans des petites entreprises
dans des très petites entreprises on
doit avoir aussi les garanties là dessus
mais j'ai l'impression en tout cas dans
ces mots le président de la république
commença à prendre position sur des les
écrits que nous avons pu lui faire et
c'est une bonne chose moi je souhaite
parce que il ya déjà une urgence
sanitaire qui est très angoissante pour
les français c'est là quand même la
première fois pour toute une génération
y pense partie du pays
on se retrouve confiné chez nous on a vu
les inégalités façon confinement on
n'est pas allé même quand on vit dans
une maison quand on vit dans un petit
appartement à plusieurs et bien à cette
urgence sanitaire a sacré sanitaires à
ceux des six sociétal qu'on est en train
de vivre
on ne doit pas rajouter de l'insécurité
économique on ne doit pas se tenir
demain
comment est ce que je vais aller remplir
mon frigo est ce que à la fin de cette
crise sinal bon ce ne sera pas pire
qu'avant
merci les gars effective qu on demande
aux français sont celles là ça ne
marchera pas merci à vous merci pierre
jouve est d'avoir répondu à ma question
je rappelle que vous êtes porte parole
du parti socialiste